We're still a few months out from the release
of Joker, the film from director Todd Phillips
in which Joaquin Phoenix takes on the role
of Batman's arch-enemy.
But it's already sparking controversy among
DC fans with a possible plot twist that would
add a whole lot more than just a name to the
Joker's origin story.
Citing a "source close to the production,"
We Got This Covered reported on May 27th that
Joker might be set to include a contentious
curveball: the Clown Prince of Crime and his
superhero nemesis Batman are actually related.
The film will apparently establish this personal
connection by revealing that Arthur Fleck
— the real name given to the Joker in the
upcoming movie — is actually the product
of an affair that Bruce Wayne's father Thomas,
played by Brett Cullen, had with Arthur's
mother.
"She told me I had a purpose.
To bring laughter and joy to the world."
For those of you keeping score at home, that
would mean that the Joker is Batman's half-brother.
This isn't the first time this rumor has cropped
up.
We saw it last year, along with other hearsay
that has since proven to be true, including
Robert De Niro being cast as the talk show
host Murray Franklin.
If that's the case here, it seems like a pretty
logical way for Joker to connect itself to
some version of the larger Batman mythology.
We've known for a while that Cullen's Thomas
Wayne was going to be depicted as a more antagonistic
character than most moviegoers might expect
considering previous incarnations of Batman's
dad, and the plot twist even makes sense from
a casting standpoint.
The part of young Bruce Wayne will be played
in the film by Dante Pereira-Olson, a child
actor who previously played the younger version
of Phoenix's character in 2017's You Were
Never Really Here.
Hey, if one casting team thought they looked
alike, the Joker gang might have, too.
Though the Joker has never been revealed as
the half-sibling of Bruce Wayne in the comics,
the Dark Knight has been previously portrayed
as having a villainous brother.
Back in 1974, Thomas Wayne Jr. was introduced
in the pages of World's Finest #223 as the
older brother Batman never knew he had.
As the comic explains, Thomas Jr. had been
hit by a car as a baby, and the resulting
brain damage led to him being raised in Willowood
Sanitarium rather than Wayne Manor.
The Waynes never got around to telling their
other son about him before they were murdered
in Crime Alley, so Thomas Jr.'s return came
as quite a surprise to Batman, especially
since Junior was being manipulated into murdering
people with razor-sharp boomerangs.
He then got his body taken over by the ghostly
superhero Deadman, who used it to get a job
at the circus.
A modern version of Thomas also exists, and
while he keeps the name and some of the basics
of the origin story, the direction of the
character was very different.
He used the name "Lincoln March" to run for
mayor and operated as an assassin for a secretive
Gotham City cult.
He told Batman that he was actually Thomas
Wayne Jr., born prematurely as a result of
a car accident, and proved that Martha Wayne
had come to visit him when he was growing
up at the Willowood Orphanage.
A DNA test, however, proved to be inconclusive.
The "Thomas Wayne Jr." name was also used
for Owlman, Batman's counterpart on an alternate
Earth where the heroes are all villains.
However, none of those characters have ever
operated as the Joker.
In fact, in the comics, the Joker has never
been given an official "real name" or origin
story for who he was before he took a dip
in a vat of acid and emerged as one of Gotham's
greatest terrors.
Even The Killing Joke was intended as only
a possible origin rather than a definitive
one, and there have been several intentionally
conflicting origins published since.
So if the rumored "Batman and the Joker are
brothers" plot twist in Joker turns out to
be true, it would definitely give viewers
something they hadn't seen before.
Catch Joker in theaters on October 4th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
DC characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.